je sais pas si vous avez remarqué et
quand on retire de la thune aux
distributeurs ça se passe toujours comme
ça
sérieux là vous pouvez vraiment que j'ai
fait une vidéo sur dépenser de l'argent
bah ouais je vais pas faire toute ma vie
uniquement des vidéos sur l'été des
actions du quotidien
1 déjà je crois que j'en ai fait
beaucoup et puis au bout d'un moment
j'ai un petit peu envie d'autre chose
j'ai envie de me diversifier m'épanouir
je pense que ça peut se comprendre
donc non cette vidéo n'est pas une vidéo
sur dépenser de l'argent je pense qu'en
cherchant sur youtube vous en trouverez
peut-être mais je vais vous parler un
petit peu de ce que je fais en ce moment
de ce que je vous prépare et
naturellement ce pourquoi je fais un
petit peu moins de vidéo ces derniers
temps elle même si je compte bien
refaire un plein très bientôt
ce qui m'a juste une petite remarque par
rapport à ce que je dis bon c'est bien
cet avis et tout mais on s'en bat les
couilles
bah non je pas d'accord je pense que
contrairement à ce que tu dis les gens
ça les intéresse aussi de pas de
connaître un peu mes projets artistiques
tout ça quoi alors je me permets
d'intervenir mais je pense qu'il a
raison on s'en bat les couilles
bah ouais t'es abonnés ils veulent une
vidéo marrante du divertissement enfin
pas du blabla quoi un bon en tout cas
moi ça me fait plaisir de partager un
peu mes projets artistiques avec vous
parce que on dirait pas forcément comme
ça mais pas la création c'est ma passion
et ça occupe toute ma vie en fait donc
je vais pouvoir vous en parler et puis
teese est un petit peu sur ce qui arrive
bon on en vient à la grande nouvelle 1
la plus grande nouvelle de toute ma vie
bien plus importante que youtube il ya
plus important ce que tout l'univers du
moins pour moi je vous l'annoncé
officiellement
désormais je suis papa watts
c'est la plus belle chose au monde
je suis je suis hyper heureux c'est un
truc de ouf du moins ça doit être un
truc de ouf parce que pour tout vous
dire je tourne cette vidéo avant le jour
j
avec ce soir ne pas être dérangé pendant
que je devrais m'occuper de ce petit
être c'est beaucoup de changements dans
ma vie j'ai je dois tout repenser c'est
juste tellement de responsabilités ça je
le sais et en même temps tellement de
bonheur bref j'en reprendrais pas tous
les quatre matins
parce que c'est ma vie privée qui
n'appartient qu'à moi et ma famille mais
je trouve ça important de vous le dire
parce que déjà c'est une donnée cruciale
dans ma vie et ma carrière entre
guillemets et puis ça me fait plaisir de
vous l'annoncer quoi alors je souhaite
me consacrer à 100% à cette nouvelle vie
sans pour autant arrêter les vidéos ou
les projets artistiques mais quoi qu'il
en soit il faut savoir que
mon rôle de père un peu bizarre de dire
ça ce sera évidemment ma priorité
maintenant que cette info cruciale a été
dit je reviens un peu dans l'artistique
si en ce moment je suis moins présent
sur youtube c'est aussi parce que je
prépare mon deuxième spectacle depuis
plus de six mois je l'écris et je le
joue quasiment tous les soirs au pana
marc de café
ma salle de stand-up de prédilection
c'est là que j'ai écrit mon home et
spectacle c'est la famille tous mes
potos humoriste il joue d'ailleurs vous
venez quand vous voulez c'est gratuit
injuste je crois le prix d'une console
contre réserver à l'avancé parce que
c'est complet tous les soirs dont je me
l'étais des infos ce spectacle j'y
consacre énormément de temps et
d'investissement et beaucoup de coeur
maintenant je suis si fier du résultat
et de pouvoir le jouer pour vous sur
scène j'espère qu'il va rassemblera
autant de gens que pour le premier
impliqué 400 milles à venir le voir donc
encore merci pour ça surtout que
celui-ci je risque de le jouer pour les
francophones de plein de pays du monde
bref plan n'est pas plus je vous dirai à
plus tard en tout cas en exclusivité
voici la fiche de ce nouveau spectacle
ouais elle est encore qu in progress
pour l'instant j'ai 35 minutes de
spectacle sur scène
donc ça avance bien et j'en profite pour
caler une petite date exceptionnelle que
je fais la cigale avec plein de poteaux
humoriste je vous mets les infos ici ce
sera en avril
j'ai plus pensé mais je au montage je
serai tout va bien les gars moi ça va on
sait juste un peu chier mais vas-y
continue mais il fait quoi l'autre à lui
l'écart en partie un effet une pause il
a appuyé en a [ __ ] un super bon
s'enrichissent toujours ok je continue
et j'ai l'honneur d'avoir été contacté
par une grosse plateforme de vidéos dont
la première lettre est la même que la
première lettre de mon prénom
nous y ait eu une hideuse ls
on encore travailler sur un programme à
la fois à scénariser et en même temps un
peu improvisé complètement cool pour
être honnête c'est vraiment l'un des
projets qui m'excite le plus en ce
moment donc j'espère que ça va se faire
je croise les doigts
football
en parallèle avec wedia on développe une
série de science fiction que j'avais
écrite il ya un an et demi en fait et
qu'on reprend que maintenant c'est un
projet très ambitieux sur plusieurs
épisodes
je passe tout seul de réaliser un
coauteur avec moi et tout alors je me
suis lâché 1 l'histoire ça se passe
légèrement dans le futur intense à un
lien peu avec notre époque
bref je pas trop en dire pour pas
spoiler un peu frustrant mais vous
verrez bien on sait pas encore à quelle
diffuseur ça va être destinée donc que
peut-être une plateforme de vidéo
peut-être qui m'importe c'est d'écrire
une belle histoire qui me plaît après le
reste
bon d'accord donc je fais que des
projets en dehors de youtube superbe
c'est quoi je démissionne c'est quoi
voilà c'est vraiment parce que j'ai
aujourd'hui je reprends je vous rassure
la suite concerne uniquement youtube il
ya pas mal de trucs donc mais comment
que j'avais fait avec ludovic mon court
métrage le bloc des 10 millions que
j'avais adoré faire et que vous aviez je
crois beaucoup aimé aussi c'est la vidéo
dont je suis le plus fier de toute ma
chaîne vous et il paraît que vous êtes
le spécialiste mois le compteur de ma
chaîne youtube est bloqué je sais plus
quoi faire
à combien 9 millions 999 1999
vous avez dit combien eh ben on recolle
à bord ensemble pour une série sur la
chaîne youtube donc pour vous le même
style que le bol des 10 millions avec
une toute nouvelle histoire donc uran
sans doute plein de poteaux de youtube
dedans et d'ailleurs donc ça c'est bien
cool j'ai bien hâte de tourner ça
d'ailleurs tout est écrit là y'a plus
qu'à tourner je prépare aussi pour ma
chaîne youtube un tout nouveau court
métrage que je fais avec cyprien qui
mêle à la fois des prises de vues de
fiction classique et en même temps autre
chose mais ça c'est une surprise si je
le dis ça ça casse tout le concept
donc je je ne dis rien désolé c'est un
peu la vidéo de la frustration puisque
je ne dis rien je ne montre rien mais
bon moi je t'annonce bon ben voilà c'est
pas mal ça enfin du contenu youtube des
promesses des promesses
j'attends de voir un bon allez je
préfère une petite vidéo de mcfly car
les tôles à cette partie de la voir
justement énorme dans un tout autre
style j'ai lancé sur ma chaîne youtube
mon petit concept une journée avec j'ai
fait le premier épisode avec jamie et en
a plein d'autres qui sont en préparation
je veux faire ça uniquement avec des
gens que j'aime bien à des artistes ou
personnalités que j'admire en mélangeant
des moments de vie et des petites
interviews un peu détendus d'ailleurs le
prochain invité je peux vous le dire
allez petit teaser subliminal d'accord
donc en fait tu deviens le nouveau
laurent boyer quoi c'est qui laurent
boyer c'est ça ton projet moi je connais
thierry boyer mais évidemment tous ces
projets bas et coûte très cher surtout
quand ils sont nombreux faut bien les
financer et parfois j'ai finance
entièrement de ma propre poche son
retour sur investissement et ça me fait
plaisir par exemple mon court métrage le
bug des 10 millions je vous balance le
chiffre 1 il a coûté 70 millions euros
et pourrait transport avec vous les
vieux tubes sa rembourse absolument pas
un mais quand c'est pour un projet
artistique qui me tient à coeur
bah je suis prêt à le faire et je suis
très content un taux va bien mais du
coup parfois ça peut m'arriver de faire
une petite vidéo sponsorisés pour
m'aider à financer ce genre de projet
vent du jeu pour avoir un pourcentage ou
bon je crois que c'est le moment de
faire une petite conclusion
enfin même si je sais que les vidéos un
peu classique que j'ai toujours fait ce
que certains appellent les podcasts va
vous plaisent énormément chez que
d'autres aiment un peu moins
paradoxalement c'est les vidéos qui font
le plus de vue donc
les gens ont un avis différent ce qui
fait aussi la richesse des viewers je
suis toujours à l'écouté de vos
commentaires que je lis qui souvent sont
très constructif et plein d'amour
je vous rassure un heureusement y'a pas
que ça j'essaye de lire tous vos avis et
puis d'en tenir compte le plus possible
c'est aussi pour ça que je fais cette
vidéo c'est pour vous parler avoue mois
dans tout ça ben faut aussi que je
trouve ma place que je fasse des choses
qui me plaisent qui m'intéresse vraiment
au final ça se ressent quand une vidéo
elle n'est pas sincère de thé des fois
je fais des vidéos parce qu'il faut
produire du contenu absolument sur
youtube ça marche comme ça et puis vous
le ressentez en fait ça vous plaît pas
et moi non plus tout vous dire parfois
je tourne une vidéo je la regardais fait
tiens c'est de la merde et quelques
semaines par exemple j'ai fait une vidéo
un podcast sur la mode et ça a donné ça
il ya des gens qui sont obsédés par les
marques de fringues est vraiment que ça
qui compte pas du tout le reste du
vêtement
mais en même temps c'est vraiment le
gâcher autant le trimestre et de 10,6 en
même temps c'est vrai qu'il m'a dit tu
ne rentres aux non pas parce que t'as
pas même si comme nous comprend et
d'être avec toi
la prochaine fois qu'on sort ont tapé
surtout si on va chez darty n'était pas
assez bien à mon goût alors finalement
gelée par claude et j'ai perdu du temps
de l'énergie de l'argent mais voilà
c'est ça aussi la création prendre des
risques parfois se tromper et
recommencer donc parfois on pensait que
je fais rien mais je fais des trucs
c'est juste que je ne mets pas en ligne
parce que c'est trop nul
moi j'adore bosser pour rien en fait
c'est ça un plaisir alors même si
j'adore faire les vidéos sur les petits
trucs du quotidien comme par exemple
faire à manger
si je vous jure j'adore faire cette
vidéo repérée des petites choses de la
vie quotidienne et qui m'amuse et puis
les mettre ensemble et voulait partager
c'est un truc qui me plaît beaucoup
depuis toujours que je fais d'ailleurs à
la fois en vidéo est aussi un peu sur
scène donc je vais continuer à faire sur
deux vidéos et en même temps j'ai envie
de nouveauté envie de me diversifier
envie de m'épanouir dans ce que je fais
même si je me suis déjà un peu
diversifiée en faisant des fictions tf1
qu développe des clips des rencontres
mais j'ai encore envie de nouveauté donc
désolé pour ce petit laps de temps ma
chaîne youtube est moins fournie en
contenu je pense qu'en regardant cette
vidéo vous comprenez un peu pourquoi
j'en profite pour vous remercier d'être
là après tant d'années
dix ans bientôt le temps passe tellement
vite je le dis ici parce que finalement
j'ai assez rarement l'occasion de le
faire dans un sketch une fiction vous
êtes 11 millions trois cent soixante
mille franchement j'ai jamais réussi à
réaliser ce chiffre mais en tout cas ce
que je sais c'est que aujourd'hui
depuis pas mal de temps maintenant là je
vis la vie dont j'ai toujours rêvé
et ça je dois uniquement à vous qui a
gardé mes vidéos et qui venait à mes
spectacles
donc merci du fond du coeur pour ça je
vous dois tout et je veux me battre pour
continuer à produire des vidéos ou des
créations à la hauteur de ce que vous
attendez le plus longtemps possible en
m'adaptant à ce que vous aimez tout en
essayant de vous surprendre et en
m'épanouis sens aussi moi même et je
vous promets que je le ferai parce que
depuis toujours passer avant tout ma
passion il t'arrive cola tu perds c'est
pas j'ai une conjonctivite d'un coup là
bon ok ok j'ai pleuré j'ai plein avec
tes conneries là à merde
bah désolé j'ai dit ce que je pensais
c'est tout bon finalement j'aurais
peut-être dû faire une vidéo sur
dépenser de l'argent en fait foi
[Musique]
oh